can you imagine this so you played it
Texas yeah and obviously playing
football but could you imagine an
assistant coach paying recruit and the
head coach not knowing that he paid a
recruit six figures not really no I
don't think that's quite possible even
with that like the comment you just made
you know this did a Rick Pitino or a
head coach as he say from the beginning
before it even starts hey if you do some
you know things behind the scenes here I
don't even tell me I don't even want to
know let's just keep them separate well
you kind of know by saying that
regardless so no I don't think you can
look at any top-notch coach at any level
and think they're not aware of what
their assistants are doing how important
do you think shoe companies are in all
the college athletics Oh extremely
I think shoe companies but more really
across the board I do think they take
more or have more of a power stake in
the basketball world but I think two to
two companies are two sets of people I
look at that are more powerful in sports
than I think people realize one being
agents to being shoe apparel that would
be both of those just think are under
the radar to the everyday fan you don't
realize how much power they have behind
the scenes the shoes because of the
money the cash they can throw around
they can influence these kids and
coaches the kids at a young age the
agents they control the inventory and a
lot of the sports and they can make
deals to broker other deals and they do
they have a lot more power than I think
people realize well what people don't
understand is we look at college
athletes getting an agent and I'm told
high school athletes are already or
somebody a third party is talking to an
agent because especially if you're a
basketball player why are you waiting
until you get out your freshman year one
and done they already have an agent or
they're in the process of hiring an
agent while they're still in high school
yes hands down especially in basketball
you're right about that basketball is a
sport that a lot of times because of the
AAU world and all that I played AAU
basketball and was around some of those
guys like remember Troy Murphy who
played in the NBA to Notre Dame I was on
his AAU team they're there they got
people hanging around them and all over
them from a very young age you're right
and none of them really play past
sophomore year in college so the agents
make sure yeah they have a friend or
they know somebody that knows him to
keep in contact us
the good side definitely happens
football not so much maybe every now and
then if you got such a superstar that
they thought wow this kid they like
senior year in high school special let's
you know get our hooks into them as
freshman year in college maybe but
that's rare but you don't think someone
like Leonard fournette going into LSU
would already have something lined up I
don't think so no no I don't know I
don't think it's as a parent in in
football just because maybe after his
freshman year this guy looks like a pro
running back looks kind of like a freak
I mean this guy is a freak first of all
Leonard fournette
I don't I just want everybody to
appreciate it I'm sorry to even change
the subject but like to me when I watch
him he's bo Jackson he's really special
we have to remember he has no
quarterback to help him it is literally
like hey Leonard there's nine guys at
the line of scrimmage
here you go make something happen but we
had questions on for net he had gained
weight he didn't play in the bowl game
he he was better in the first part of
his college career yeah okay so why did
team's question and maybe miss out on
well I don't I don't think anybody
questioned them once you turned on the
film that he had the ankles issue right
I mean LSU I checked the rule books
they're allowed to have a good offense
there every now and then great
quarterback nothing I mean you know that
I used to like make me laugh on
everybody would go well Les Miles beats
90% of the team over 90% yeah well he's
the better team on the field 99.9
percent of the time so he's losing nine
getting nine percent of the games that
he shouldn't so regardless the guy is a
freak of nature to be 240
I mean he's run the two fastest mile per
hours I think in football if you look
like next-gen stats you know like one of
those things they do his lue outlast two
runs nobody's running as fast as he has
the whole year he's to me how fast is he
running
he's like 23 you guys can look at I'll
do something by 30 miles an hour
something like 23 miles per hour B he
has a two fastest recorded mile-per-hour
times of the seasons over at 240 pounds
that's crazy
at the end of the football one at the
end of the football game one of the
start is Carolina using Christian
McCaffrey correctly they they are you
know the big thing that hurts them is
the fact that Olson went down so then
now everybody can kind of put their
right you know they're their focus
lights onto McCaffrey a little bit more
but I do think that maybe they could
give them the ball a little bit more
than the traditional running back sense
you know between the between the tackles
a little bit he is capable of doing that
he's good like avoiding big hits but for
the most part yeah I'm pretty excited
with the way they're using them as a
past receiver you know one of those
hybrid type running backs but aren't
they trying to you incorporate the
Patriots offense here in Carolina I I
don't think so no I don't think they're
capable of that I think I thought that
Mike Shula said hey we're gonna try to
adopt that for Cam so he's not taking
those hits and staying in the pocket too
long sure sure I mean if they want to
but I don't see that when I watch film
and go oh they're running New England
stuff no I mean New England stuff is
complicated having played for Josh
McDaniels and worked up there they're on
another level then the rest of football
just plain and simple I don't really
know how to other said I'm not trying to
be mean or disrespectful than any other
coaches but they're crazy up there then
our inventory of plays are they playing
chess and everybody's playing check
without a doubt yes they are they are
here and everybody else is there and
it's the number one thing that I think
gets overlooked with the New England
Patriots and their greatness is the fact
that their coaches out-compete the other
teams coaches six days prior to the
matchup every week Belichick is a
curmudgeon he's gonna sleep on the couch
fine no big deal he's got no wife at
home his kids are in the building with
him he's got nothing to hurry home for
Oh twenty hours a day in the office no
problem 15 years ago if I said you can
start your team with Bill Belichick or
Tom Brady 15 years ago you asked me that
who well let's see 15 years ago Brady
had already won a Super Bowl I would
still probably get on madela check
though yes I mean to me Brady is I mean
he's Tom Brady I'm never got a check
can't get injured though no you're right
and below check to me is still the
wheels of that place I mean eleven and
five with Matt Cassel I think they still
go to the Super Bowl last year with
Jimmy Garoppolo I don't know if they
come back from 28 to 3 but they go to
the Super Bowl and I'm saying that my
dad was a quarterback that got hurt and
the backup quarterback went to the Super
Bowl so that's no disrespect to anybody
there I just think that balichek yes is
on another level and that whole staff is
but explain this to me if you're Jimmy
Garoppolo right
you know the Patriots he's got the same
agent as Tom Brady right ha how does he
not know what's going on that wouldn't
you at some point say if Tom's gonna
play five more years you know let let me
go well I think this is it for him I do
I think he's gonna leave he's gonna he's
not gonna stay there any longer you can
wait for Tom Tom is playing better now
than he was four years ago so Tom might
played another two or three more
pictures Elle has anything to say about
this no I don't I think Tom you know she
might have a little say about how he
dresses in the postgame press conference
but that's where it ends Tom loves
football I can attest that your mom have
anything to do say anything to say about
your dad or even you playing yeah my mom
would like yes I mean not my playing
wise but like if I had like I mean
health oh yeah no no she had no say in
that none in fact my data his last year
here he woke up one day for a game
against the Cardinals in November in
1993 and he was sick as a dog and my
wife my mom my mom said to him well you
better just go suck it up she happened
to tell like Steve sir be at the time
who said the Daily News was like what
would you tell him and she goes I told
him to suck it up the next day and he
put it on the cover the pay for the next
day would you tell your wife if you had
a concussion yeah I would I've had tell
her but I would also lied to the coaches
and the medical staff if I thought I had
a concussion abbrevs said he wouldn't
tell my wife oh yeah I would tell my
wife I don't know you know I don't even
she might not even care I don't even
know how many concussion do you think
you okay so I I mean I had some
concussions outside of football cuz I
was a idiot hit by a car I've done some
dumb things in my life okay wait how did
you get hit because I didn't look I was
racing a friend and they his driveway
went across the street into my driveway
and I didn't look up and down and I got
a well all my teeth here are fake and I
got yeah 60 stitches here over a hundred
stitches in my face yeah at the age of
12 yeah I've had better days
so that was one confession but
football-related I never got like
diagnosed like we said you got a
concussion
I definitely got my bell rung in which
this day and age means a concussion yeah
but I
even think anything of it I probably say
three three times where I got up and I
was like whoa why there's three Dan
Patrick's there for a second hold on but
I don't know if this concussion protocol
is really working because it still feels
like Luke Kuechly grabbed his shoulder
right now he's still in concussion
protocol and then they said he didn't
have a concussion yes that's like
flu-like symptoms it feels like he still
had the flu but he grabs his shoulder
right and I think that that is just
something that's ingrained in you is
don't say you know something's wrong
with my head definitely my shoulder and
of all the people in the NFL it feels
like we're waiting for that next one
that could be the final one you're from
Kuechly you're right it's scary with
Luke Kuechly he's wearing that thing
around his neck right like the
woodpecker thing that keeps the blood in
his brain and all that and I've even
when I watch him on film I go he doesn't
never hit with his head anymore he
really does it he like tackles people
with his face more than more than not
but the concussion protocol thing I'm
with you it's hard to justify and really
I just wish they'd get rid of it and
find some way that all the players can
sign waivers like I was never under the
you know under the false pretense that
running into Ray Lewis at full-speed was
good for my brain or my health I was
pretty aware that at a pretty young age
all right welcome back with Chris Simms
and we'll talk about tonight the
importance of tonight's Chiefs game
against the Raiders the Aaron Roger les
Green Bay Packers are they still a
playoff team so a few things talked
about and Andrew Luck does he play again
this season so a few things talked to
Chris about will do so right after this
Dan Patrick show how important is this
game for Brian Kelly at Notre Dame it's
a huge game for Notre Dame in general
yes Brian Kelly certainly it's been
widely documented about the year they
had last year and him being kind of on
the hot seat sure
I think he's silenced those rumors to a
degree I mean I don't look at him as
being on the hot seat anymore really
yeah I don't I think that well I think
they're a good enough football team I
think they had to be like you know four
or five losses for him to be fired at
least in my eyes I mean this is not an
easy job let's let's take that into
account you actually have to be smart to
go to school there too which doesn't
make it any easier to be the football
coach but I do I think they're a good
football team in fact I think they're
underrated and is that crazy because
Notre Dame most years I go damn I'm so
sick of hearing about note
name they're over rating him this is a
year I look at them and going they are
legit football team and if they win on
Saturday night I think they're legit
chance to be in that final for
conversation they're ranked 13th USC is
ranked 11th I know that you've been
vocal on bleacher report talking about
Sam Darnell that you're not all in on
Sam darn old in this is not now you're
talking about last year when we saw him
play great why yeah well he has a lot of
things you like there's no doubt about
them he's a good thrower the football
he's a very good athlete he is a gamer
all those things he's natural at the
position my first thing that I that at
least brought red flags to me when I
watched him last year as I said ooh the
motion then which he throws with them I
have I don't you can't show me any
quarterbacks in the NFL or really a lot
through a history that had that motion
that have been successful it's a very
long Tim Tebow ish type of motion right
I'm not gonna say it's Tim Tebow and he
throws the ball better than Tim Tebow so
I don't want that to be lost in this
conversation but it does worry me and
you've seen it this year a little bit he
has definitely lost control the football
at times it forget the bad
decision-making and some of that stuff
the fumbles whatever maybe I'm just
talking about the purely from the
physical standpoint I'm not sold on it
yet and I think there's a lot of other
good quarterbacks this year in this
conversation you know two times we look
like you know I'm sorry I'm gonna take a
shot at your old Network youth sports
center anchors determine the who's the
number-one pick Sports Center told me
that Matt Barkley was the number one
pick for two years ago and that didn't
happen so you know I think it's still a
lot to be evaluated and seen best
quarterback in college football today is
who the one all right so not Pro gonna
know just best quarterback Baker
Mayfield if you have to win a game right
now
yeah the quarterback you want to speak
her mind going with Baker Mayfield i am
i think just his you know his moxie the
way he just he seems to thrive under the
lights he's a very good athlete and he
is a legit NFL arm I mean I've made some
comparisons I think he's very Russell
Wilson ish in his play and the way he
does it yeah I really do I think he's a
guy that's gonna be when draft time
comes around I think people are gonna go
oh this kid
a little bit more talented and better
than you you expect and so when you see
him on film you go man those are legit
throws he might not be the best
quarterback in his state um you're
you're right he may not be because
Rudolph is legit now Rudolph would
probably be the guy right now I would
probably give the edge to as the number
one quarterback as far as the NFL is
concerned yes I mean he's big he is a
big-time arm he's a good athlete as well
he's a lot like the Josh Allen kid at
Wyoming and you and I were talking off
air I mean I know people are trying to
jump off the Josh you know I like it I
like it even more I want to see you
struggle yeah you want to see you have
to play without you know without you
know let's say you throw the ball you
know one yard into the flat to Percy
Harvin and then he runs for 90 yards to
Reggie Bush I'm 5 for 5 I threw the ball
so you're right there is something to be
said about that it was one about about
evaluating Carson once a few years ago
at North Dakota State they weren't just
gonna steamroll people every week so you
had to see him make some physical plays
what you're seeing now with the Eagles
and it's translating I had a couple of
NFL things here would you pay Odell
Beckham jr. more than anybody else give
him the biggest contract in the NFL I
would make him the highest-paid receiver
for sure more than anybody else no I
still don't think that position is as
important as a quarterback and and and
again the guy that's best in football at
any position is Aaron Rodgers so he just
got hurt too but I wish he didn't play
this year I really do he shouldn't have
not for 1.8 million when you're the best
receiver in the game but I think the
Giants will treat him correctly and at
least get him in the ballpark as being
my the highest-paid should Eli Manning
be back next year
yes one more year I would say would be
appropriate it's it is getting to that
time let's say they have the seventh
pick in the draft yes okay
I still think would you take a
quarterback yeah I would certainly think
about it everything I know and I've said
this on pro football talk with him with
Mike Florio and everything to everything
I know the Giants wanted to trade and
get Patrick mahomes this year they were
very much in the conversation for
trading up to get Patrick mahomes so
that tells me that they're obviously
thinking about life after Eli and that's
coming and I'm sure they have their eye
on a few of these guys in the draft or
the Packers still play off to I would
say no I can't I mean the
is all Aaron Rodgers I mean really the
last few years this is like a six and
ten seven and nine football team that
you know number twelve just does magic
and things I've never seen before so no
they're gonna have to change the way
they play offensively and it's not that
impressive what they do as a whole
scheme wise and their defense isn't
great no I say no how do you explain
Aaron Rodgers if somebody knows nothing
about football and you said watch this
guy because why I would say watch this
guy because he has the strongest arm in
the history of the NFL he has the
quickest release in the history of the
NFL within Marino yeah it's it's right
there with it for sure and it's longer
that Randall Cunningham and Elway had
strong on high this guy is yes I'm
telling you you and it's unanimous
anybody I've ever talked to whether it's
Troy Aikman Phil Simms any ex
quarterback when they see her and Roger
snow in person everybody goes holy crap
it feels more finesse because of his
feet his footwork is now you could say
best footwork I've ever seen with a
quarterback yeah it's it's amazing what
he does and then of course I mean you
guys see it the way he wheels and deals
this way that way and he can do it so
effortlessly that you're right it
probably doesn't do it justice on TV
because you just go through that 30
yards it didn't even look like a tried
it can't be that hard he's the greatest
one-man band I've ever seen in the NFL
just where I say on a week to week basis
one guy has to play good or this team
can't win and he delivers almost always
the difference between Jared Goff this
year in last year's one Sean McVeigh
that is the biggest difference because
golf is certainly better than last year
but McVeigh that offense it's special
what they do i when I watch them on film
I go this is the best design defense in
the whole game right now everything they
did are than the Patriots yeah I think
so yeah I do it and then you know I love
the Patriots offense but I just yeah
McVeigh is so creative with not only the
run game the screens finding exotic ways
to get the ball down the field for golf
but McVeigh is a special offensive mind
Kansas City hosting the Raiders tonight
yeah how I'm more important for the
Raiders are the Chiefs Raiders this is
it for this is the season for the
Raiders I mean I heard you saying when I
walked in it was a big game for them and
I'm with you I mean this is it's do or
die
you go to and
five there's just there's no way there
one in the division and it's highly
unlikely you're gonna get a wild-card
berth I don't see it happening I don't
know I don't think they can win tonight
the only reason I would say I give them
some chance is the Steelers and the
Chiefs played the most physical game of
football I've seen all year on Sunday so
maybe the Chiefs will be beat up but the
Raiders are built for their offense to
take over and that has not happened this
year I mean it's the 30th ranked offense
and footb are you kidding me with Derek
Carr that old line Amari Cooper
beastmode Crabtree Clyde Wofford you
know cooks at Titan
there's no way so that's really the
issue with the Raiders explain to me how
Ben Roethlisberger can have doubts in
the offseason and express those and I
and I know that he can be a drama queen
at time all right and and he'll tell you
things almost as if to set it up if he
doesn't play well because hey I told you
I didn't know anymore okay you have the
best quarterback wide receiver running
back Trillo in football yeah right yeah
why I mean I the doubts in what went on
with Antonio Brown here like how do they
get to this point yeah Berg that's they
are a little bit dysfunctional that way
well it just what happens to when you
got a lot of personalities on your team
but do you think Ben purposely did not
throw that ball to Antonio Brown for a
touchdown does he not know he didn't
mean to do that I mean Big Ben likes
himself more than Antonio said he would
have liked to have the 70 or a touchdown
pass on their resume yeah it's just they
have some personalities they were
certainly frustrated but the way we saw
them play last week or even you know two
weeks ago they're trying to play the way
they did at the end of last year which
is Smash Mouth we're levian bells
offense and then big been a few times
the games like three or four times we
just need you to make a big throw to get
them over the edge and I think that'll
be the formula going forward the defense
is better than last year it is a lot
better it is a lot better and I picked
them to go to the Super Bowl you know
what happens you're I get angry at the
team like Seattle I pick them and
how dare you let me down yes do you
understand Seattle I feel like they end
up talking too much yeah there's too
much going on there instead of just
going out like they did a few years ago
and they just played football and they
rely on Russell Wilson way too much I
mean I would look at Russell Wilson
second to Aaron Rodgers as the most
indispensable guy in football I think
he's up there I agree it's very close
it's a one-man show why don't they
approach the game that you're down 14
points to start the game right just say
you know just say Russell do whatever
you need to do make it a pass stop
trying to pretend that you're still this
2013 beast mode like running a football
team that's it's gone shut the door
you're right I think you're spot on just
open it up let him throw it all over the
field let him run around let him make a
mess of the defense and then they'll be
so tired from chasing around then you
can run the football but their offensive
line stinks
their defense is another year older you
know the Seahawks are good they're not
great I don't think they can I was kind
of with you to start the year but from
what I've seen just I thought with
Richardson there Thomas back I know I
thought all the same thing way Russell
played in the preseason I said watch out
for the Seahawks this year they might
have the Mojo back but I I got to see
more evidence a good play before I say
that again is there a great team in the
NFL no you know what's scary is
everybody's just kind of hanging around
just they're just hanging around so New
England can just keep getting better and
take this thing over at the end that's
really what it seems like to me I mean
the Chiefs are the best team for for my
money yes but a one-game showdown with
Tom Brady in the playoffs who you guys
picking Tom Brady yeah thank you right
we all are yeah but Paulie we have an
i-team report coming up after the break
bowling during the break we want to see
if Chris wants to dust off the gun oh I
don't thing to throw it a fake face or a
real face another Patrick so this is we
had this at Mardi Gras this was our
parade float and it's supposed to be me
I thought it looked like George Bush now
Patrick mahomes dented my nose there
right okay I think got something to live
up to Shawn watched and peppered my face
- so we'll give you 2 throws during the
commercial ok great let's see how's your
if it's good I'm in shape I'm a little
better off than Andrew Luck right now
would you perform better would you have
a better chance of playing than Colin
Kaepernick thank you for the team sign
yeah yeah yeah he ain't get inside I
don't think he plays again I don't think
you don't see all right NBC Sports
presents college football's greatest
intersectional rivalry that Saturday
night it's Notre Dame its USC and Chris
Simms will be part of that also pro
football live co-host with Mike Tirico
thanks for coming in thank you we'll be
back right after this Stan Patrick show
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]